vous voulez je vous libère ouais voilà
traite 1 c'est beau ça dans trois plats
et voici agnès varda
voilà donc john travolta est à 4
c'est confirmé on vient de le voir sur
ces images
[Musique]
m
flavio rick hansen love you can't we
love you can do that or à cannes oui
c'est bon un cap
j'adore 4
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'espagnol que ce soit
vous avez remarqué comme dans le film
certains l'appellent show oui et donc
l'appel chewbacca et vous il est décrit
comme moi je suis chauvin car souvent le
cas parce que le bisou il est pour moi
le reste et pour les spectateurs
oui parce que le film sorte de babu est
dans quel état d'esprit vous connaissez
c'est bien que je suis incapable de
sortie à quoi que ce soit qui tiennent
debout
c'est un complément d'objet un verbe
je suis tout à fait capable je comprends
que vous soyez mi temps quand on va vous
laisser maintenant je suis très très bas
est ce que alden était un bon partenaire
il ne parle pas je pense tout bas cas
non voilà c'est quatrième film qu'on
fait ensemble et j'ai jamais filmé
vincent autant de face
alors que d'habitude j'ai pu être temps
de trois quarts dos de deux profils au
maximum et là il ya quand même quelque
chose de frontale avec sa parole
voilà donc pour ces immigrants au
cadreur qui réussissent à passer de l'un
à l'autre là cette écurie c'était
presque alors même s'il est maintenant
très impressionnant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
georges place est venu le premier jour
sur le tournage avec vous quelle est la
recette de giorgio cash et il m'a aussi
dit quand tu as dit vous fait appel à l'
enfant de 12 ans qui est en toi
l'exploit est retombé guide demande toi
ce que ce gamin de 12 ans voudrait voir
ressortir d'une scène a carrément
[Musique]
et
il ya en avait la projection la des
chatouilles en quelques jours dans quel
jeu joue mais pour tout corriger la fois
les de l'avion et qui ont fait l'acteur
producteur et qui a été un moment
magique tu sais comme les plus dans un
temps canon va être très dur très
violent il ya des moments et super
amoureux
y faire empathique avec le film c'était
un moment magique c'est très chouette
savoir les apprécier ces moments là
parce que voilà tu as vingt minutes de
gens ont les larmes aux yeux qui
applaudit ses supérieurs
[Musique]
merci merci merci